[Music]  hollywood is simply one of the coolest  places in cali it happens to be where i  was born and raised and lived my whole  life in the 9046 area code  there are so many reasons to visit this  area the iconic hollywood sign is  certainly one of them but there is  amazing food and interesting  neighborhoods to walk around an old  spanish hollywood architecture to marvel  at  by the way could you tell i'm from  california  i mean  i am stuck with this accent for my whole  life and i couldn't be more proud if  there's anything more callie about  someone than this kind of accent i'd  like to meet them  drew's cali is sponsored by visit  california